hey everyone Avengers infinity war has
donated a pop-culture discussion in
recent weeks with one recent TV spot
featuring Doctor Strange confirming the
possibility of time travel in this movie
What did he say exactly and what
implications do his words have on
infinity war and the broader MCU welcome
to new rockstars news our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week so
yeah we're also gonna talk about the
Batman solo film Game of Thrones final
season it chapter two and some troubling
news about Stan Lee that keeps cracking
up Tommy Beck told BC doesn't have a
heart
[Laughter]
joining me at the table are my friends
in mid sip hello it's Sam hi my name is
Bob Melina nice a little boy wished to
like the little boy said no thanks look
it up I think you used that one before
go through every single time wiki page
to find all our intro bits if it doesn't
exist get on and friends okay let's get
started with our top story of interest
infinity war it's probably gonna be our
top story for the foreseeable future
everybody you're welcome Marvel has been
blanketing the airwaves with a series of
new TV spots with interesting teases of
major elements in this movie we've been
breaking down the juicier spots I broke
down that chance spot early this week
and mr. Sam bashed her over here broke
down the most recent one that came out
yesterday it should be on the channel
very soon but perhaps the most
interesting detail came out in a
different spot in which Doctor Strange
tells Tony Stark that he travelled
forward in time to see all the possible
outcomes stark asks if they win in any
of those outcomes and strange just
stares grimly back at him and then the
trailer cut away to something else so
this is confirmation that time travel
via the time stone will happen in some
form in this movie but it brings up a
lot of questions as to what exactly
strange meant by this is he implying all
the possible outcomes led to their
defeat so they'll just need to try a
completely different tactic and their
fight against Thanos or does his grim
expression suggest that the only outcome
where they succeed is one where one of
them
iron man sacrifices himself or are we
looking at a scenario where this could
mean that's some of the footage we've
seen in the trailers are actually just
part of these hypothetical outcomes that
strange sees like a a nose wiping Iron
Man or body-slamming spider-man are
those real things that happen are they
just part of the Thanos kills everyone
montage that just gets reset kind of
like the ending of Doctor Strange that
movie so this line also clarifies how
the time stone works say the loud
strange to travel forward in time to see
what happens but not necessarily
influence any past or future events okay
so I've been talking a lot I want to
affirm you guys what you think dr.
strange meant by this how does this
revelation change what we know about the
MCU well real quick too isn't it is it
Guardians had also had alternate
versions that we saw do you remember
that it was like like different ways
that they kept dying you wanted one of
the Marvel movies are something from the
last like five years whatever also did
that age of Ultron right it was kind of
just like I like they described like so
then we'll do this and then they get
like smashed and killed and then it's
like I don't know which one was right
now but my point is it could be that
exact things or something spider-man
homecoming where that happens sounds
like a movie they would do it um I don't
know if it might have been the first
Guardian yeah yeah I think that takes
the piss out of this movie if you were
to do something like that to do way they
bit again of showing like the alternate
like futures also it's like guys we're
allowed to kill everyone we want kind of
it's like it's like hypothetically
they're dead in another timeline
somewhere but really everybody lives you
all can buy the toys when you can go
home it's everybody can't buy toys of a
dead character it's illegal you can find
if you know who to ask
Tommy toy yourself
now and follows reanimated iron man toys
in my doesn't take the piss out of it I
think that it's because we both are
referencing a lot of times when we talk
about infinity war in the comics when
you see the way that Thanos destroys the
Avengers it's so fun to see that that I
think it'd be worth it to just
straight-up see him like you know pop
their heads and do every single little
thing you could do even if it meant like
and then we got to undo it or ever I
just want to see that on you know what
is it 70 foot IMAX yeah I just hope they
don't burn through all that in this
movie because they already have five for
war at least different storylines
they're going out at the exact same time
and then one of them is having a
time-loop thing going at the same time
like that so that's a lot that's a lot
to deal with well if it is what I think
it might be is there's an episode of the
show community which the Russo brothers
directed many episodes of where the
character Abed like they are playing a
game where he roll the dice and he the
whole episode is structured off of
there's a different storyline for each
of the numbered dice that gets rolled so
you see these different alternate
futures and in his mind he kind of sees
like six different timelines for him
and I wonder if the Russo brothers are
trying to it was considered one of the
best episodes of community and I wonder
if they're trying to do the same thing
with Avengers infinity war where you
just see dr. strange as that characters
quickly just maybe not as like a huge
crush Cage is moving next Doctor Strange
you said he's only looks forward but 70
spider-man doing fan like fiction of
like way apart of this I'll say I think
though that if I had to put money down
on what I think is happening I think
it's gotta be it happens in a lot of
time-travel movies
it's the you do time travel and you mess
things up so bad and end in failure
which is what dr. strange eluding is
telling doing that again and again and
again again every time but also if you
ever saw the cartoon show Mighty Max if
anyone saw that the series finale of
Mighty Max is
then baling and then it starts back over
this series premiere like our kind of
thing but my team acted that a couple of
things that have done that just that
idea that like well we messed it up so
bad we got to go back to the beginning
and then beginning a place for mm-hmm
interesting and you start all over again
different actors same movies different
kinda yeah I'll say they do a different
take on you know Ironman a couple the
Iron Man movie sort of her that's the
one obviously I think that it's most
likely to recast well it's kind of fun
about this possibility as it sets up
like wish fulfillment right like we
don't have to have every matchup be like
a fateful depending or determining the
end result of the movie battle we can
just see the Thanos matchups against a
ton of different characters and just
kind of like test the waters with each
other we like that needs to be paid off
so many of these movies like
peripherally like he needs to kick a lot
of ass and they said he's gonna be the
most he has the most screen time in the
movie right visit him and then ya know
what was interesting is we we kind of
were talked about this a bit later but
they have you know there was lots of
different versions of the script that
went out and there was rumors that like
not everyone on the cast read the holes
really no one that no one did there was
an interview I think on Graham Norton or
some British talk show where was like
Tom Holland and Benedict Cumberbatch and
a Loki actor Tom Hiddleston and they
write yeah I know so there's like 20
names I have to remember that honestly
our life but they all asked like which
have any of you read the complete script
and they'll appointed to Benedict
Cumberbatch so even if he hasn't read
the PostScript I feel like Doctor
Strange will have a lot to do in this
movie it
that confirm your theory that there are
different timelines we're gonna see and
so the people that read their scripts
they read their timeline and where that
goes and he as you know the master of it
all has to be able to see you just want
to know that oh that would make sense
yeah don't know yeah but I I just hope
that like time travel doesn't doesn't
break it you know like it's so easy it's
so hard as a you know when you're
writing a script or when you're even
watching a movie for time travel to to
be introduced and for it to still make
sense like at most you could just
introduce it for like one chapter of
your story and then back away from it
the way like prisoner of azkaban
introduced the idea of time turner's and
then Game of Thrones Season six
introduced the idea of time travel and
they never addressed it again these
that's a complete game changer so I hope
it's something that's just like
introduces a piece of this story but not
something that is like the complete
third act that would change everything
that we see in the MCU be is you know as
nerds those like thought experiments can
just be like dead not want it I wanted
them to go I'm serious I want them to go
all at it I want them to make not the
mistakes but I want them to hit it like
primer did we're like we're gonna have
charts after we're gonna have to be like
timeline a1 is this oh man I'm like
geeked up it up so primer is I I've
heard many time travel fans that love
time-travel movies it's like the one
that you're supposed to see it's the
hardest one it's like reading an essay a
little bit it's not so much like
narrative payoff and actors are just
like there's Stanford grad students who
wrote and acted in this movie so it's
just went on time remember got with
Annie from community oh yeah both of
them there you go mmm if you're gonna do
time travel I would say I like your idea
of it just being visions and that way
it's like you're not affecting anything
really it's just like as soon as you see
it you can get a line up like well since
I saw it I don't know if I can even if
they saw the best version of it they're
like don't know if that means we can do
it it just means that like we could
maybe do it and the fewest amount of
people could die yeah so everyone's a
lot of people go die and hopefully if
they do use it it be something that like
justifies some questions that we've had
for past MCU movies my mind eight years
later that is that would be the reason I
you know I doubts that
but and like how sure are you guys that
a lot of people are gonna die in this
movie there's a teaser currently that I
did I talked about in the video I do
there's a character having a reaction
and needing to be held back and so
you're like whoever this person's
attached to yeah based on other clips of
you seeing who's around at the same time
you're like mmm that person probably
didn't just get like flick trail right a
lot of people are thinking that's a
fight scene mmm didn't think no no
that's like a fight and I agree with you
I think it's because there is another
clip that came out later of Aria another
reaction you're like no ideally because
they shot multiple things for different
trailers so they're like can get a
couple different expressions and we're
good yeah yeah well let us know you are
hoping for with this time what is your
theory on what Doctor Strange meant by
that line do you think it's something
that was just shot for the trailer as
many of this as we've seen in the past
oh I put it as a shot for the trailers
they I want you to do it and I down the
movie
how do you think the time travel is
actually gonna go like whoever wins
whoever gets it exactly right
gets a shirt off of you yeah yeah let us
know but in the meantime let us move on
to this week's trivia question it kind
of stays in this theme so it is yeah
Doctor Strange theme since he's kind of
the star of this people were reading
ahead on what the question is cuz I
usually put it on prompter instead of
teasing me with you put the answer there
- okay
the in Doctor Strange when he comes to
bargain with Dormammu trapping him in a
time loop to her mom who threatens him
by saying you will suffer what callback
line does strange stay a say in response
okay those are all of our answers in the
in the little tub there and later in the
show we will reveal the answer to the
trivia question the closest answer as
decided by our judge
we'll do our sign off goodbyes and they
can do in whatever voice they want to do
tank takes always teasin to come back
but
never quite makes it happy a lot of
letters about tank being offensive to
[Music]
military we lost a lot of advertisers
meanwhile the loser of our trivia
question as the cyber judges will have
to cleverly riff on our in other news
headlines it's always a treat right down
Muldoon I wrote down multiple answers
just a kind okay before we move on to
another story a quick update with some
breaking news this week Jake Gyllenhaal
confirmed in an interview that he will
actually not be playing the Batman wire
it remains unknown what exactly the
future is for the Caped Crusader but for
now Ben Affleck is still attached to
play there's some people who have very
specific like really striking physical
features if Bruce Wayne in that world
had those baby blue eyes that you can
fall into that's slightly extended
tongue yeah you can't even get that bad
boy in his mouth you know you know that
that was you know who Bruce Wayne was
immediately obvious yes and the show
Black Lightning Kris Williams has the
the best beard I've ever seen on any TV
show and then he puts on goggles and
you're like I know that B I know that
beard it's one person I was excited I'm
let down I'm saying okay well let us
move on cheer ourselves up with some a
game of Thrones news updates on the
final season that you know I wouldn't
consider these to be spoilers but if you
want to go into season eight completely
blind you know maybe skip this section
but really I don't think have anything
to worry about okay an Instagram post by
an assistant director on the show's
final season thanked the crew for their
work on the show's longest shoot an epic
battle sequence he says it took 55
consecutive nights 11 weeks in three
locations predicting that when viewers
see the episode it'll be something
that's never been done before
until now the longest shoot on Game of
Thrones was the Battle of the bastards
in season six which took 25 days to
shoot now it doesn't completely surprise
me that a nighttime shoot would take
longer than usual from a production
standpoint it's a lot more complicated
shoot stuff at night but this also gives
another reason why the show's production
might have pushed back to the winter
time because of course nights are longer
in the winter give them more hours of
Darkness to shoot in
so you guys without those boiling or
speculating too deep into spoiler
territory but what does this update tell
you about the show's final season
finally using real dragons difficult to
shoot when you have a dragon on set I've
worked with many dragons fabulous
traitors and they're difficult to
control and I believe that they probably
killed real people as well so that's my
speculation as to why it took 55 days I
liked it yeah I think these actors are
going to show a lot of wear and tear
like just grumpiness and I think it
actually will read is like like
somebody's gonna win an Emmy off of the
season because they were just upset the
whole time yeah I also want to point out
that I they said that this is not the
longest shoot they'll have before the
end of the series
Oh which other ones are meeting yeah so
I think that this actually tells me that
this is probably the mid-season yeah
they probably don't want their actors to
want to come back cuz I wouldn't want to
come back at the end of that 55 days are
you kidding me a night shoot for tonight
55 nights sometimes look upload bill
pictures to me this like we're looking
okay we're looking at six episodes and
from everything we've heard each of
these episodes is gonna be like its own
movie feature like they're extended
they're gonna be like 80 or 90 minutes
long so when you're talking 55 days
shoots on one sequence that's like what
goes into a film production like most
film productions are like on average 7
or 8 weeks for a big movie
that's 11 weeks I mean they probably
shot this over the course of 11 weeks
Game of Thrones normally has like three
different crews once in Belfast once in
Croatia ones in Spain so he might have
been using those numbers to talk about
like the other crews as well he said
three locations but in this case he was
talking about one episode worth of
content that we're gonna see this is
it's gonna be wild calls it this for the
night dragons dragons at nighttime I
mean if you if you're following the
Watchers on the wall and other like
leaked sources which you know I try to
avoid you might know so I would avoid
those kind of things I shouldn't even
told you about it but there are there
have been some leaks of like what this
battle could be so yeah just try to gird
your loins it tells your the Knight
Rider could be a hint
to that dragon from How to Train Your
Dragon and I feel like it's a prequel
but also over in the making
[Laughter]
okay let's move on to another quick
update here about its chapter 2 part 2
of last year's Stephen King horror movie
is scheduled to begin shooting this July
focusing on the kids battle with penny
wise 27 years later Jessica Chastain has
signed on to play the adult version of
Beverly meanwhile Bill Hader and James
McAvoy are also in talks with McAvoy to
play bill the the group's leader and
hater to play the wisecracking Richie
that was Finn wolfhard from stranger
things characters John
right in the original one yeah he played
the adult Richie right oh yeah which is
it's just interesting because I
remembered I think we talked about this
back in October and they asked each of
the kids who they wanted to play the
adult version of then I think Bill Hader
was spin wool Ford's choice to play the
adult version of himself so I guess you
know they're just letting little kids
run Hollywood now right you could bring
a child into this world or just take an
existing I'm vain I need my kid to look
like me that's a great option everyone
should be a adoption is an option that's
something that should be a slogan right
yeah okay well not too dark in the mood
let's uh but let's move on to some
actually some troubling news about
Stanley though of course the Marvel
Comics visionary creator of characters
like spider-man the x-men Black Panther
several other characters that we all
know and love
okay guys an investigation by The
Hollywood Reporter claims that Stan Lee
may be the victim of manipulation and
elder abuse since the death of his wife
Joan last year's Lee who's now 95 years
old appears to be under strict control
of his daughter and her associates which
some believe might not be operating in
his interests Lee and his wife had
previously set up a trust for their
daughter the 67 year old JC Lee to give
her exorbitant but fixed payments
throughout reportedly tumultuous
relationship in the family but since
Joan's death JC has allegedly been
trying to pressure her father resulting
in Stan firing his longtime lawyer who
had co-signed a document with Stan
criticizing Stan's daughter and then
JC's friend then had Stan make a video
distancing himself from that document
it's very complicated now Jay sees
people have also allegedly limited Stan
Lee's contact with his longtime
assistant from daily check-ins to weekly
supervised visits
stan has also fired his longtime
housekeeper and gardener and now new
accountants and lawyers were hired for
him his phone number has been changed
and they are now reportedly sending and
reading his emails for him they say it's
because he has you know failing vision
but who knows what's really going on
this report is long it's filled with
insane details guys you can go check it
out in your own time if you want but
perhaps the creepiest detail I want to
single out is one associates merch idea
to blend Stanley's blood into special
DNA ink for pens and for stamps which
they say Stan was cool with but um yeah
sure okay and then Stan leaves estate
guys is estimated to be worth between 50
million and 70 million dollars he
reportedly receives a 1 million dollar
payment a month for his ties to Marvel
and of course he appears in all the
movies now we cannot verify how much of
the claims in this article are a hundred
percent accurate but it sounds like Stan
Lee has a lot of really dark forces in
his life that are just trying to make
money off of them Kevin Smith has
actually offered to let Stan Lee live in
his house it's not necessarily like I
don't know if he's under physical threat
other than this creepy blood Inc idea
but it just sounds like he's got a lot
of just people who have different
emotions yeah Stan Lee's responded to
all this recently he said that like he'd
sue anybody that like were to like keep
talking about his daughter that way and
in that forum did he he was I think your
text I think it was audio like that part
I don't know where it came from but he
said it was all untrue and he said that
this like their lies and he'll take
action for people accusing his daughter
and this is not we are just you know
we're not saying it's Maureen what The
Hollywood Reporter has said and we don't
necessarily believe everything in this
article but suffice creepy
what what is the most into yellow like
that's what I'd like to know how
attendees
whatever lamps are the very least yeah I
think what it's kind of troubling you if
you read this article they talk about
Stanley's responses and they were many
of them were in videos released by some
of his daughter's people's we don't know
how much he's really under control over
what he's saying or I mean when you're
under the emotional influence of someone
who knows what you're really in control
of especially isolated yes your own
daughter who you would trust implicitly
now I think it's really hard for us to
comment on what is actually happening
without knowing and especially like you
know just speaking like personally for a
second if it were me as you know as a
child like it's complicated you know it
gets so complicated that you just like
you can't understand what their family
dynamic is right now but I feel like we
can talk about the the whole thing that
kind of launches thing which is the
convention appearance throws multiple
days of getting in line for autographs
and pictures with Stanley and people
were like this guy couldn't you know
hold his arm up anymore and they were he
what he would fall asleep literally
between like one person comes up and
then he would fall asleep as they walked
away and they just kind of shake him
awake him out and they'd like all right
Stan right s T and he had dad to spell
his name for him this guy was like
completely out of it
and that they the end of having to
refund a lot of people because they
never got to them in the two days that
it was all supposed be like one signing
session so it that's kind of I think the
inevitable thing is Stanley too old for
these kinds of appearances right cameos
all that and I and to put even if he's
interested is he is he too old or do we
have right to retire and yeah he
deserves like a retirement right the
guys had such a great career and given
so many great things to the world like
let him live the rest of his life but
maybe he doesn't want it like well some
of the people involved in this are
people who do all of its booking they
have a stake in him going out on these
appearances and and inspiring things
yeah and they charge and they make a cut
of that so I don't know how much his own
comic-con that's coming up soon so it's
like he's got to kind of be there and
looking for the most part unless someone
can unless he can actually speak up and
does not actually want to go but he
probably does because of
he created partially this entire
industry but what's what's scary about
this is like when you hear that he's
like firing people who have been
lifelong yeah it does sound strange but
also like coming from a personal
experience you don't know how family
dynamics work getting older you start to
like sometimes people start to lose
trust and you get overly anxious or I'm
blanking on a word I'm trying to like
look for in my head right now
I don't know but basically you you start
to make really rash quick decisions that
you like this this seems totally out of
character and sometimes that just normal
and who knows maybe this is ADD looking
at this completely through the wrong
lens it could be these longtime
associates were people who were like
manipulating him for decades and then
finally when his wife passed away the
people or she might've been the person
who's protecting those manipulators and
then finally people like no we're gonna
clean shop and rescue you it's just it
is impossible to know it's just it just
presents kind of a warning sign for
anyone who's successful and gets older
like it's hard to know what those
constants are in your life and what
sources should you trust I think the
question is and beginning to hear each
of your answers would you still write
now you know pay for a ticket to get
Stanley's autograph after hearing the
story you just told I don't think I
would cuz I think it would I would feel
guilty if I got up there and he
struggled to sign his name and had to be
told how to spell it I wouldn't blame
anyone for wanting to you know be around
someone with that much contribution to
things that we love right but for me
personally I think it would be too much
of a bummer if he was really that bad
off I don't think I'd want I've seen him
like give a speech at a convention and
be very full of life and like that would
be good for me a better way to remember
him by like rather than have this new
terrible memory yeah yeah I I wouldn't
go do it just yeah because I don't I
know any time with these fan events and
comic-con and all these different things
there's lots of different like
stakeholders and those things it's an
industry and of itself and I get that
like money goes lots of different places
but just the ID out in it and it seems
like Stanley's not enjoying it so I you
know I'm happy with just like seeing him
pop up in in different MCU movies
remembering him as the great crater that
he wasn't is you know just looking at
that I wouldn't I kind of had a special
back SourceFed nerd days forgot she had
to do a video with him and that was very
special it was like we don't like shoot
separately to put his part into the into
the video but he like was so full of
life and like he we gave him a line
that's all I had to say was like no but
he was like all good this way and he
like he's a I'll do it this way and I
could came up with his own ideas for it
so it's just like cool that's it that's
all I want I don't want to it whatever
you're going through now that's I don't
want to have any small tiny little hand
into making it worse so if he wants to
do that that's on him and like everybody
said you shouldn't feel bad if you do
want a signature from him because he's
still there and that's how it's working
so it's like but again us nothing yeah
without elongated a discussion I would
just say that you know all of us I also
feel the same way would not do it if
there is a thing that is kind of like
are we forcibly retiring him are we
choosing to retire that guy who was
chosen to do it that's just an
interesting thought that you know yeah
but maybe not everyone knows about this
so going to a convention you just
wouldn't have any of this variation
going into I think the best takeaway is
for everyone whether it's people were
close to him or fans it's just like let
him make his own decisions and live his
own life and stop looking for ways to
benefit off of him and just you know I
don't know rather than just assuming you
know what he wants just want his blood
that's it yes little bit I mean how much
blood could he possibly have like a pint
I mean look at me it's not specific this
family oh my god P o box 1906 Studio
City California
nine one six one two I don't know blue
or new rock stars news lightning round
straighten my co-host
you guys gotta answer these questions as
quickly without hesitation as possible
there's side conversations I don't care
if I got a move on I'm scared of where
we're going
all right here we go Sam you know event
Isiah e93 wants you to rank the agents
of shield villains from worst to best
hive aid award at dr. Leopold
yeah worst worse the best there you go
right at the time we'll do it all the
good ones hive at the bottom then a ward
ADA and then dr. Leopold the top there
you go at one fjc oh it's coming back
with another great question do you think
we'll see pepper donning her iron suit
and would you even want to see rescue
being introduced into the MCU Wow I'd
rather pepper Ann no I don't think so I
actually do think it'd be kind of cold
but I do not think that I happen to know
how to end how do you think it will in
but how your selfish little heart wants
it to end how do you wanna Deewar to end
not how you think it will end but how
your selfish little disagree let's think
about this I think I want it to end in
my selfish little heart with everybody
just getting along and hugging each
other and Thanos going I look like
grimace and Bruce Willis and this is
what has become of me now so I'm a Bruce
Willis grimace hybrid and I'm gonna go
my life in McNugget land with Mayor
McCheese and the Hamburglar and all the
fried kids and that's how I would thank
you yeah what are the Nuggets in that
world are they animals their eyes are
more evolved in the Nugget sociology of
McDonald's land right now McDonald's is
also where I was called no nuts
Brian blade look what you've done
okay the three options when you got
let's see Eric I've got three options
read through picture title for Avengers
four Eric's pitch a title for Avengers
for the Diana ok Avengers 4 so we have
infinity War of Industry infinity work
Avengers for how Thanos got his stones
back to Jamaican hooks up with thank you
for all your questions guys and keep
those tweets coming but next up we'll
take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel in the next week of course we
have Sam made a video that we talked
about we're doing that in Avengers
infinity war Legacy TV spot breakdown
that's what they're calling it
I'm doing that also the final embassy
rewatch Doctor Strange cuz Eric and the
team at New Rock sirs actually did those
we're just a year out now so there'll be
the last one I'm doing so hopefully you
guys are excited for ya guys also on
Sunday we have the season finale of The
Walking Dead Season eight I will be
doing a breakdown of that and I will be
delighting four out of five of you with
my negan and Rick impressions and then
we also I know if you saw this just
breaking today was a trailer for
Incredibles 2 we had two teaser come out
a couple months ago and we have a full
trailer now so we're gonna do a video on
that we also want to do we teased this
last week but we had some late-breaking
trailers come out over the week
and we want to do a video on Hawkeye
like what's going on with him why isn't
he in any of the promo stuff he'd start
do pop up at some of the promo stuff but
they have a reason for not putting them
in so much we haven't really 'cimmanon
in the video a guess we have submit yeah
it's always on my private YouTube
channel 30 minute plea to my ex-wife let
me see my horses again I just live
stream each time I just want to see my
horses I just want to be a little misty
he does mean human daughters 15 seconds
shout out or each of us is 15 seconds to
shout out plug or ramble about anything
they want Sam take it away you can check
out my podcast only stupid answers
because we've been doing movie reviews
pretty regularly button for extra weird
fun stuff that's McDonald's lane related
you should go to grimaces Wikipedia page
dear Lord
okay I might have talked about this last
week I think Sam actually might have
liked a quiet place horror film that was
actually number one at the box office so
I don't really hurt I need to give
attention to this but it's so amazing we
just did a video about the ending and
some of the questions that you might
have had coming of the movie but man
it's one of my favorite horror films
that I've seen in recent years I say
that about most horror film said if they
were to get out one of my favorite you
know they're all great but this one
sound design is brilliant yeah cool
ii-i'll keep it the time-travel theme
from earlier type in a or Q on Netflix
it's called Ark and it stars Robbie
Amell but it's a decent time travel
movie for like a real low-budge one
decent so if your time travel head
you'll like it if you're not typing
something else how Stella got her groove
back Sheila let me see my horses please
I only have 11 more seconds but I miss
my horses also if you want to cry again
KOCO is available for digital download
and purchase and rent this dr. Sheila so
I'd watch KOCO again if you just gotta
flush the water out of your face she
might call crying
Sheila are you out there
finally let's return to our trivia
question that we asked earlier and let's
question it was in Doctor Strange when
he comes to comes to bargain with
Dormammu trapping him in a time loop
Dormammu threatens by saying you will
suffer what callback line does strange
say in response it's gonna line I got
Philip and he wrote this is pretty close
I think it's follow at fimo on Twitter
nice little plug before the end do it we
never get our plugs and now we got this
show because apart yeah oh there you go
that's smart all right uh bottom line
Bechtold says that's what she said three
come back yeah when did he also say told
you so yeah your name is that's what she
said Erik Bosse wrote suffers my middle
name dr. Stephen suffer strange no that
sounds weird my parents hated me this
sounds like a thor ragnarok joke I'm so
meta oh it's a game yeah birthday I'm
glad none of us took this seriously
except for Sam now I'm in Paris great
answers I can do this all day
or I've got all the time in the world
okay and
[Applause]
bruce willis women okay we we've all
learned our lessons and dancer was pain
is an old friend is an old friend yeah
pretty good judge when you have
processed answer yeah yes i think sam
yeah he might have done that but temple
or would he have said that's what she
said she said is pretty funny because he
said that you're gonna suffer great so
as i mentioned before sam as the winner
will get to our sign off goodbyes philip
as the loser will have to do all the in
other news headlines i'll read the
headline philip will have to come up
with a riff on the spot at the end of
the headline yeah does that work for
everybody
hmm all right great and here we go in
other news advance ticket sales were of
interest infinity war are higher than
advanced sales for all other previous
MCU movies combined higher than that sam
watching this movie when it comes out
like a STONER all right next up the
creators of Westworld announced on a
reddit AMA that they would spoil the
entire second season to preempt any
online leaks releasing a video that
turned out to be a rick roll prank it's
weird because that video doesn't look
like anything to me or has said they
wrote a fake script pages to keep the
plot a secret and that no one in the
cast knows the full story of the movie
so unfortunately this movie will not
come out is no lines people are just
wandering around and on screen no one
was ever given a script and it was a
huge mistake 20 hundred billion dollar
jews enters the scene he sets up the
scene everyone yes and direction for
Star Wars story essentially right yeah
now the director of Pixar's upcoming toy
story for announced that the release
date will be June 21st 2019 and the toys
will be man it's just like it's like
screaming sex toys
okay dark turn available on Bechtold
comm there's one more Handmaid's Tale
author Margaret Atwood has said that she
believes Star Wars inspired the 9/11
terrorist attacks it's like like a
Madeleine Madeleine something terrible
something beloved an author people
respect and popular Hulu Channel great
lightsabers don't melt she'll be like
man it was good
one of our better ones for sure win one
don't mess it up thank you for watching
this week's episode of new rockstars
news I'd love to thank our hosts say hi
it's me Eric a follow up Molina but you
already got a plug Tommy back so at
Tommy Beck told do you ever what's your
YouTube channel where you can get your
white where the wife was were supposed
to subscribe come back horses and it's
on his desktop like this video share it
around and only stupid answers you can
find me there's podcast I I bungled that
at the end also on grimaces Wikipedia
page it basically says he was last seen
entering home work for you guys do a
supercut at the end of all of these
videos gonna put them all together and
send them to our parents to shame my hey
I love you all so much
so at McDonald's I wanted a sundae with
no peanuts and then the next time I came
back the cashews said I remember you
know nuts a little boy what a hot day
when you wanna Sunday you can
what kind of 60 or it comes with
McDonald's by himself he looks good oh
yeah I love you all so much I love you I
love you